There's a good chance you've either
played flappy bird or at least you've
heard of it it's easy to play you simply
tap the screen to make the bird fly and
avoid obstacles you get points for
successfully avoiding the pipes but if
you hit them or crash into the ground
the game is over.
Flappy bird was highly addictive so
much so that it ruined the life of the
guy who created i. At one point, Dong
Nguyen was making $50,000
a day on the game from ads yet he
removed it from the App Store and Google
Play less than a year after its release.
Why did he walk away from what appeared
to be such a success?
Our story begins in Hanoi, Vietnam in
2013. Dong Nguyen was a 28-year-old
programmer who lived with his parents. He
made a living programming location
devices for taxis. As a teen, he was
obsessed with video games like Super
Mario Bros and also learned to code. He
played the app Angry Birds but thought
it was too busy, there was too much going
on. That inspired him to make Flappy Bird
over one weekend. He wanted to make
something simpler that you could play
while on the go. His company .Gears
released the game on the App Store on
May 24, 2013. It went live on Google Play
in early 2014. he decided the game would
be free he hoped to make a few hundred
bucks a month from the ads within the
game but little did he know the fortune
that lay ahead.
Initially, Flappy Bird didn't attract
much attention. Tens of thousands of new
apps come online every month. Competition
was tough.
However, about eight months after
releasing the game something strange
happened. People started talking about it.
Really talking about it. How they were
addicted to it. How they were frustrated
by it. How they couldn't stop cursing
after losing.
Flappy Bird adhered to Atari co-founder
Nolan Bushnell's principle: the belief
that all the best games are easy to
learn and difficult to master.
Whenever you played, you felt like you
could have done better and that made you
want to try again and again. The game was
all about skill.
Most people usually lost within the
first 10 pipes or so - you got a point for
every gap you passed through. If you got
10 or more points you did exceptionally
well.
The physics was especially impressive
Flappy Bird was inspired by the act of
bouncing a ping-pong ball against a
paddle for as long as possible. Whenever
flappy nose-dived, you felt you were
along for the ride. Whenever flappy died
it wasn't so much that flappy died but
you died. By January 2014, the game topped
the charts. It was the most downloaded
app in several countries including the U.S.
It helped that PewDiePie reviewed it
on his YouTube channel. There we go baby
here we go.
Why is it so hard?
By February 2014, Flappy Bird had been
downloaded more than 50 million times
netting Nguyen $50,000 a day in ad
revenue. You'd think he'd be the happiest
man in the world
but no.
On February 8, 2014 he tweeted that
Flappy Bird was ruining his simple life
and that he grew to hate his own game.
The following day (local time) he tweeted:
I am sorry Flappy Bird users. 22 hours from now I
will take Flappy Bird down. I cannot take
this anymore.
This came as a shock.
Why on earth would anyone remove a game
that was so insanely popular generating
$50,000 a day even after Apple and
Google's 30 per cent cut of the revenue?
Instead of being thrilled about his
success, he was very very unhappy.
In an interview with Rolling Stone a
month after taking the app offline, he
said he found the sudden intention
suffocating. He said his parents didn't
know about the game until the paparazzi
showed up outside his door.
When journalists started reaching out to
him for interviews he pleaded with them
to "give him peace".
Even worse than the media attention was
the criticism from some users. He had
intended for the game to be played for
just a few minutes at a time as a
relaxing break but in reality, that's not
how people use the app. They were
addicted.
He showed Rolling Stone a message he
received from a woman who chastised him
for "distracting the children of the
world." Another person wrote: "13 kids at my
school broke their phones because of
your game and they still play it because
it's addicting like crack." Nguyen
apparently took these messages to heart:
"...at first I thought they were just
joking but I realize they really hurt
themselves. In an interview with Forbes
shortly after taking the game down, he
explained it happened to become an
addictive product: "I think it has become
a problem...to solve that problem it's
best to take down Flappy Bird.
On February 10, 2014 Flappy Bird was no
more.
Knockoffs soon flooded the app store. It
was a valiant effort but people still
craved the original. Some tried selling
their smartphones with Flappy Bird
already downloaded for as much as
$100,000. The game was still
playable there just wouldn't be any
software updates. However, one seller said
eBay canceled his auction because the
company policy was that the phone had to
be restored to factory settings before
it could be sold.
After the demise of Flappy Bird, fake
news stories swirled around the creator.
The satirical side Huzlers claimed the
Flappy Bird creator had committed
suicide. There were suggestions Nintendo
had threatened to sue him which he
denied the popular gaming site Kotaku
attacked Flappy Bird's creator for
allegedly ripping off Nintendo's art.
Kotaku later ended up apologizing.
The addiction, the spotlight, the
criticism all proved too much for Nguyen.
It appears money no matter how much
really can't buy happiness.
Nearly two years after the end of flappy
bird, Nguyen appeared to be in a much
better place.
In December 2015 he tweeted: "I'm really
happy these days. I finally have a team
that I fit in and we work together well.
Not alone anymore." He came out with a
bunch of other games and he said that if
users thought they were too addicting he
wouldn't hesitate to take them down as
well.
But luckily for him, none would come
close to the success of Flappy Bird.
if you'd like to create your own app or
product a strong background in STEM is
really important. My go-to tool for
brushing up on science, computer science,
and math is Brilliant. If you'd like to
learn how to make a computer do what you
want, Brilliant's Algorithm Fundamentals
course is a perfect place to start. By
the end of the course, you'll have an
understanding of the methods to measure
and compare performance, and you'll have
mastered the fundamental problems in
algorithms. Brilliant is great whether
you're in high school, university, or if
you're already working. It's full of
interactive questions like these.
My personal favorite are the Logic
courses. In this example, you have to put
things in the correct order. They get
harder as you go along and build up to
some truly mind-bending challenges. There
are no tests and if you ever get stuck,
you can view the explanation to see
where you went wrong. Brilliant is FREE
to try out if you head to brilliant.org/newsthink.
My custom link is in the
description or pinned comment. And the first
200 people to use my link will get 20% off
Brilliant's Premium subscription
which gives you unlimited access to all
the offerings. Thanks for watching. For
Newsthink, I'm Cindy Pom.